Vous êtes beaucoup.
Et pendant quelques semaines ?
Voilà une quantité raisonnable.
Quelques mois ?
C'est plutôt bien.
Maintenant, imaginons que cette forêt
connaisse un hiver éternel.
Mêmes questions : combien d'entre vous pensent pouvoir survivre
pendant quelques jours ?
C'est beaucoup.
Et pendant quelques semaines ?
Maintenant, imaginons pour rire que la seule source d'eau disponible
soit piégée comme des blocs de glace des kilomètres sous la surface.
La quantité de nutriments dans le sol est si minime
qu'on ne trouve pas de végétation et, bien sûr, pratiquement pas d'atmosphère
digne d'être mentionnée n'existe.
De tels exemples ne sont qu'une partie des nombreux défis
auxquels nous ferions face sur une planète telle que Mars.
Comment nous préparons-nous pour des voyages vers des destinations si éloignées
de vacances sous les tropiques ?
Enverrons-nous des réserves depuis la planète Terre ?
Construirons-nous des escalators spatiaux, ou d'impossibles kilomètres
de convoyeurs, qui rattachent la planète de votre choix
à notre planète maternelle ?
Et comment cultiverons-nous des choses telles que la nourriture
qui a poussé sur la Terre, comme nous ?
Mais je m'emporte.
Dans le voyage de notre espèce
pour trouver une nouvelle maison sous un nouveau soleil,
il est très probable que nous passions beaucoup de temps
à faire le voyage lui-même,
dans l'espace,
sur un vaisseau, une boîte de conserve hermétique volante,
possiblement pour des générations.
La durée continue la plus longue jamais expérimentée par un être humain
dans l'espace est d'environ 12 à 14 mois.
À partir des expériences spatiales des astronautes,
nous savons que passer du temps dans un environnement à microgravité
signifie perte d'os, atrophie musculaire, problèmes cardiovasculaires,
parmi beaucoup d'autres complications
qui s'étendent du physiologique au psychologique.
Et que dire de la macrogravité,
ou de toute autre variation de la force gravitationnelle
de la planète sur laquelle nous nous trouverons ?
En bref, nos voyages cosmiques seront remplis de dangers,
connus et inconnus.
Jusqu'à maintenant, nous avons considéré cette nouvelle technologie mécanique
ou ce super robot de la prochaine génération
comme faisant partie du nécessaire à la survie de notre espèce dans l'espace.
Aussi merveilleux qu'ils soient, je crois que pour nous, le temps est venu
de complémenter ces géants électroniques
avec ce que la nature a déjà inventé :
le microbe,
un organisme unicellulaire qui s'auto-génère, s'auto-répare,
une machine vivante autonome.
Il n'a besoin de presque rien pour s'entretenir,
son design offre beaucoup de flexibilité,
et ne demande qu'à être transporté dans un seul tube en plastique.
Le domaine d'étude qui nous a permis d'utiliser le potentiel du microbe
est la biologie synthétique.
Elle vient de la biologie moléculaire, qui nous a donné les antibiotiques,
les vaccins et de meilleures façons d'observer les nuances physiologiques
du corps humain.
Avec les outils de la biologie synthétique,
nous pouvons désormais éditer les gènes de presque chaque organisme,
microscopique ou pas,
avec une vitesse et une fidélité incroyables.
Étant donné les limitations des machines fabriquées par l'homme,
la biologie synthétique sera pour nous non seulement un moyen de fabriquer
notre nourriture, notre carburant et notre environnement,
mais de nous fabriquer nous-mêmes,
afin de compenser nos insuffisances physiques
et d'assurer notre survie dans l'espace.
Pour vous donner un exemple
de l'utilisation de la biologie synthétique pour l'exploration spatiale,
retournons à l'environnement martien.
La composition du sol martien est similaire à celle
des cendres volcaniques d'Hawaï, avec des traces de matière organique.
Faisons l'hypothèse
que le sol martien puisse tolérer la croissance des plantes
sans utiliser des nutriments dérivés de la Terre.
La première question que nous devrions poser est :
comment nos plantes résisteront-elles au froid ?
Parce que sur Mars, la température moyenne
est d'un très peu accueillant - 60°C.
La question suivante devrait être :
comment nos plantes résisteront-elle à la sécheresse ?
Considérant que la plupart de l'eau qui forme du gel
s'évapore avant même que je puisse dire le mot « évaporer ».
Il s'avère que nous avons déjà fait des choses pareilles.
En empruntant des gènes de poissons pour des protéines antigels,
et des gènes pour la résistance à la sécheresse de plantes comme le riz,
puis en les insérant dans les plantes qui en ont besoin,
nous avons maintenant des plantes
qui tolèrent la plupart des sécheresses et du gel.
Elles sont connues sur la Terre comme OGM,
ou organismes génétiquement modifiés,
et nous comptons sur eux
pour nourrir toutes les bouches de la civilisation humaine.
La nature fait déjà ce genre de choses,
sans notre aide.
Nous avons simplement trouvé des façons plus précises de le faire.
Alors pourquoi voulons-nous changer la constitution génétique des plantes
pour l'espace ?
Eh bien, ne pas le faire générerait le besoin de créer
une infinité d'hectares de terrain sur une planète complètement nouvelle
en lâchant des milliards de mètres cubes de gaz atmosphériques
et en construisant ensuite un dôme de verre géant pour les contenir.
C'est une entreprise d'ingénierie irréaliste
qui devient rapidement une mission de transport de cargo à très haut coût.
Une des meilleures façon de s'assurer
que nous aurons les réserves de nourriture et d'air dont nous avons besoin,
c'est d'emporter avec nous des organismes que nous avons créés
pour s'adapter à des environnements nouveaux et difficiles.
Simplement, utiliser des organismes conçus pour nous aider à terraformer une planète,
à la fois à court et long terme.
Ces organismes peuvent ensuite aussi être conçus pour produire
des médicaments ou du carburant.
Donc nous pouvons utiliser la biologie synthétique pour apporter
des plantes modifiées avec nous, mais que pouvons-nous faire d'autre ?
J'ai dit plus tôt que nous, en tant qu'espèce,
avons uniquement évolué pour vivre sur la planète Terre.
Ce fait n'a pas beaucoup changé depuis les cinq dernières minutes
que vous avez passées assis ici et moi debout là.
Et donc, si n'importe lequel d'entre nous,
se retrouvait largué sur Mars maintenant,
même en ayant assez de nourriture, d'eau, d'air,
doté d'une combinaison,
il risquerait certainement de très désagréables problèmes de santé
dus à la quantité de radiations ionisantes qui bombardent la surface
de planètes comme Mars qui ont très peu ou pas d'atmosphère.
A moins que nous prévoyons de rester terrés sous terre
pour la durée de notre présence sur une nouvelle planète,
nous devrions trouver de meilleures façons de nous protéger
sans devoir porter une combinaison armée
qui pèse environ le poids de votre propre corps,
ou d'avoir besoin de se cacher derrière un mur de plomb.
Inspirons-nous de la nature.
Dans la pléthore de vie ici, sur Terre,
il y a un groupe d'organismes appelé extrémophiles,
qui aiment les conditions extrêmes de vie,
si vous vous souvenez de vos cours de biologie du lycée.
Et parmi ces organismes,
il y a une bactérie appelée Deinococcus radiodurans.
Elle est connue pour être capable de supporter le froid, la déshydratation,
le vide, l'acide et, le plus notable, les radiations.
Bien que ses mécanismes de tolérance aux radiations soient connus,
il nous faut encore adapter les gènes pertinents aux mammifères.
Le faire n'est pas particulièrement simple.
Il y a beaucoup d'aspects qui jouent dans la tolérance aux radiations
et ce n'est pas aussi simple que de transférer un seul gène.
Mais avec un peu d'ingéniosité humaine
et un peu de temps,
je ne pense pas que ce soit très difficile.
Même si nous récupérons juste une fraction de sa capacité à tolérer les radiations,
ce serait infiniment mieux que ce que nous avons déjà,
qui est seulement la mélanine de notre peau.
En utilisant les outils de la biologie synthétique,
nous pouvons récupérer la capacité de Deinococcus
à prospérer sous des doses autrement létales de radiations.
Aussi difficile qu'il soit de le percevoir,
les homo sapiens, c'est-à-dire les humains,
évoluent tous les jours,
et continuent toujours à évoluer.
Des milliers d'années d'évolution humaine
ne nous ont pas seulement donné des humains comme les Tibétains,
qui peuvent prospérer dans des conditions pauvres en oxygène,
mais aussi des Argentins, qui peuvent ingérer et métaboliser l'arsenic
cet élément chimique qui tue l'être humain moyen.
Tous les jours, le corps humain évolue par des mutations accidentelles
qui, tout aussi accidentellement, permettent à certains humains
de survivre dans des situations extrêmes.
Mais, et c'est un gros mais,
une telle évolution nécessite deux choses que nous n'aurons pas toujours
ou que nous ne pourrons pas nous permettre,
qui sont la mort et le temps.
Dans le combat de notre espèce pour trouver notre place dans l'univers,
nous n'aurons pas toujours le temps nécessaire
pour permettre l'évolution naturelle de nouvelles fonctions
pour survivre sur des planètes autres que la Terre.
Nous vivons dans ce que E.O. Wilson a nommé l'âge de contournement des gènes,
pendant lequel nous remédions à nos défauts génétiques
comme la fibrose pulmonaire ou la dystrophie musculaire
avec des apports extérieurs et temporaires.
Mais avec chaque jour qui passe,
on approche l'âge de l'évolution volitionnelle,
un moment durant lequel, nous, en tant qu'espèce,
aurons la capacité de décider par nous-mêmes de notre destinée génétique.
Améliorer le corps humain avec de nouvelles capacités,
n'est plus une question de faisabilité,
mais de temps.
L'utilisation de la biologie synthétique
pour changer la construction génétique d'organismes vivants, dont le nôtre,
ne va pas sans ses dilemmes éthiques et moraux.
Nous modifier nous-mêmes nous rend-il moins humains ?
Mais encore une fois, qu'est-ce que l'humanité,
sinon des poussières d'étoiles qui se trouvent être conscientes ?
Vers où le génie humain doit-il se diriger ?
C'est sûrement du gâchis que de rester en retrait et de l'admirer.
Comment utiliser nos connaissances
pour nous protéger des dangers extérieurs
et, ensuite, pour nous protéger de nous-mêmes ?
Je pose ces questions,
non pas pour engendrer la peur de la science
mais pour mettre en lumière les nombreuses possibilités
qui sont et seront permises par la science.
Nous devons nous regrouper en tant qu'humains pour discuter
et embrasser les solutions, pas seulement avec prudence
mais aussi avec courage.
Mars est une destination,
mais ce ne sera pas la dernière.
Notre véritable frontière finale est la ligne que nous devons dépasser
en décidant ce que nous pouvons et devons faire de notre improbable intelligence.
L'espace est froid, brutal et ne pardonne pas.
Notre chemin vers les étoiles sera parsemé d'embuches
qui vont nous pousser à questionner, non seulement qui nous sommes,
mais où nous irons.
Les réponses seront dans notre choix d'utiliser ou d'abandonner la technologie
que nous avons glanée à la vie
et cela va nous définir pour le reste de notre présence dans cet univers.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)